you're looking at a woman
who was publicly silent for a decade
obviously that's changed but only
recently
it was several months ago that i gave my
very first major public talk
at the forbes 30 under 30 summit 1500
brilliant people
all under the age of 30. that meant that
in 1998
the oldest among the group were only 14
and the youngest just four
i joked with them that some might only
have heard of me
from rap songs yes i'm in rap songs
almost 40 rap songs
but the night in my speech a surprising
thing happened
at the age of 41 i was hit on
by a 27 year old guy i know
right he was charming
and i was flattered and i declined
you know what his unsuccessful pickup
line was
he could make me feel 22 again
i realized later that night i'm probably
the only person
over 40 who does not want to be 22 again
at the age of 22 i fell in love with my
boss
and at the age of 24 i learned the
devastating consequences
can i see a show of hands of anyone here
who didn't make a mistake or do
something they regretted
at 22.
yep that's what i thought
so like me at 22 a few of you may have
also
taken wrong turns and fallen in love
with the wrong person
maybe even your boss unlike me though
your boss probably wasn't the president
of the united states of america
of course life is full of surprises
a day goes by that i'm not reminded of
my mistake
and i regret that mistake deeply
in 1998 after having been swept up
into an improbable romance i was then
swept up
into the eye of a political legal and
media maelstrom
like we had never seen before
remember just a few years earlier news
was consumed from just three places
reading a newspaper or magazine
listening to the radio
or watching television that was it
but that wasn't my fate
instead this scandal was brought to you
by the digital revolution that meant we
could access
all the information we wanted when we
wanted it
anytime anywhere
and when the story broke in january 1998
it broke online it was the first time
the traditional news was usurped by the
internet for a major news story
a click that reverberated around the
world
what that meant for me personally was
that overnight
i went from being a completely private
figure
to a publicly humiliated one worldwide
i was patient zero of losing a personal
reputation
on a global scale almost instantaneously
this rush to judgment enabled by
technology
led to mobs of virtual stone throwers
granted it was before social media but
people could still
comment online email stories
and of course email cruel jokes
news sources plastered photos of me all
over
to sell newspapers banner ads online
and to keep people tuned to the tv
do you recall a particular image of me
say wearing a beret
now i admit i made mistakes especially
wearing that parade
but the attention and judgment that i
received not the story
but that i personally received was
unprecedented
i was branded as a [ __ ]
tart [ __ ]
[ __ ] bimbo
and of course that woman
i was seen by many but actually known
by few and i get it
it was easy to forget that that woman
was dimensional
had a soul and was once unbroken
when this happened to me 17 years ago
there was no name for it
now we call it cyber bullying and online
harassment
today i want to share some of my
experience with you
talk about how that experience has
helped shape my cultural observations
and how i hope my past experience can
lead to a change that results in less
suffering
for others
in 1998 i lost my reputation
and my dignity i lost
almost everything and i almost
lost my life
let me paint a picture for you
it is september of 1998.
i'm sitting in a windowless office room
inside the office of the independent
council
underneath humming fluorescent lights
i'm listening to the sound of my voice
my voice on surreptitiously taped phone
calls
that his supposed friend had made the
year before
i'm here because i've been legally
required
to personally authenticate all 20 hours
of taped conversation
for the past eight months the mysterious
content of these tapes has hung like the
sword of damocles over my head
i mean who who can remember what they
said a year ago
scared and mortified i listen
listen as i prattle on about the flotsam
and jetsam of the day
listen as i confess my love for the
president
and of course my heartbreak
listen to my sometimes catty sometimes
churlish
sometimes silly self being cruel
unforgiving uncouth
listen deeply deeply ashamed
to the worst version of myself a self i
don't even recognize
a few days later the star report is
released to congress
and all of those tapes and transcripts
those stolen words form a part of it
that people can read the transcripts is
horrific enough
but a few weeks later the audio tapes
are aired on tv
and significant portions made available
online
the public humiliation was excruciating
life was almost unbearable
this was not something that happened
with regularity back then in 1998
and by this i mean the stealing of
people's
private words actions conversations or
photos
and then making them public public
without consent
public without context and public
without compassion
fast forward 12 years to 2010
and now social media has been born
the landscape has sadly become much more
populated with instances like mine
whether or not someone actually made a
mistake
and now it's for both public and
private people the consequences for some
have become dire very dire
i was on the phone with my mom in
september of 2010
and we were talking about the news of a
young college freshman from rutgers
university
named tyler clementi sweet
sensitive creative tyler was secretly
webcamed by his roommate
while being intimate with another man
when the online world learned to this
incident the ridicule
and cyber bullying ignited
a few days later tyler jumped from the
george washington bridge
to his death he was 18.
my mom was beside herself about what
happened to tyler
and his family and she was gutted with
pain
in a way that i just couldn't quite
understand
and then eventually i realized she was
reliving 1998
reliving a time when she sat by my bed
every night
sorry reliving a time when she made me
shower with a bathroom door open
and reliving a time when both of my
parents feared
that i would be humiliated to death
literally
today too many parents haven't had the
chance to step in
and rescue their loved ones too many
have learned of their child's suffering
and humiliation
after it was too late
tyler's tragic senseless death was a
turning point for me
it served to recontextualize my
experiences
and i then began to look at the world of
humiliation and bullying around
me and see something different
in 1998 we had no way of knowing where
this brave new technology called the
internet would take us
since then it has connected people in
unimaginable ways
joining lost siblings saving lives
launching revolutions but the darkness
cyberbullying
and slut-shaming that i experienced had
mushroomed
every day online people
especially young people who are not
developmentally equipped to handle this
are so abused and humiliated that they
can't imagine living to the next day
and some tragically don't and there's
nothing virtual about that
childline a uk nonprofit that's focused
on helping
young people on various issues released
a staggering statistic
late last year from 2012
to 2013 there was an 87 percent
increase in calls and emails related to
cyber bullying
a meta-analysis done out of the
netherlands showed that for the first
time
cyber bullying was leading to suicidal
ideations
more significantly than offline bullying
and you know what shocked me although it
shouldn't have
was other research last year that
determined
humiliation was a more intensely felt
emotion
than either happiness or even anger
cruelty to others is nothing new
but online technologically enhanced
shaming
is amplified uncontained
and permanently accessible
the echo of embarrassment used to extend
only as far as your family
village school or community but now it's
the
online community too millions of people
often anonymously can stab you with
their words
and that's a lot of pain and there are
no
perimeters around how many people can
publicly observe you
and put you in a public stockade
there is a very personal price to public
humiliation
and the growth of the internet has
jacked up that price
for nearly two decades now we have
slowly been sowing the seeds
of shame and public humiliation in our
cultural soil
both on and offline
gossip websites paparazzi reality
programming
politics news outlets and sometimes
hackers
all traffic in shame it's led to
desensitization
and a permissive environment online
which lends itself to trolling
invasion of privacy and cyberbullying
this shift has created what professor
nicholas bills calls
a culture of humiliation
consider a few prominent examples just
from the past six months alone
snapchat the service which is used
mainly by younger generations
and claims that its messages only have
the lifespan of a few seconds
you can imagine the range of content
that that gets
a third-party app which snapchatters
used to preserve
the lifespan of the messages was hacked
and 100 000 personal conversations
photos and videos were leaked online to
now have a lifespan
of forever jennifer lawrence and several
other actors had their icloud
accounts hacked and private intimate
nude photos were plastered across the
internet
without their permission one gossip
website
had over 5 million hits for this one
story
and what about the sony picture cyber
hacking
the documents which received the most
attention
were private emails that had maximum
public embarrassment value
but in this culture of humiliation there
is another kind of price tag
attached to public shaming the price
does not measure the cost to the victim
which tyler and too many others notably
women minorities
and members of the lgbtq community have
paid
but the price measures the profit of
those
who prey on them this invasion of
others is a raw material efficiently
and ruthlessly mined packaged and sold
at a profit a marketplace has emerged
where public humiliation is a commodity
and shame is an industry
how is the money made clicks
the more shame the more clicks the more
clicks
the more advertising dollars
we're in a dangerous cycle the more we
click on this kind of gossip
the more numb we get to the human lives
behind it
and the more numb we get the more we
click
all the while someone is making money
off of the back
of someone else's suffering
with every click we make a choice the
more we saturate our culture
with public shaming the more accepted it
is
the more we will see behavior like cyber
bullying
trolling some forms of hacking and
online harassment why
because they all have humiliation at
their cores
this behavior is a symptom of the
culture we've created
just think about it
changing behavior begins with evolving
beliefs
we've seen that to be true with racism
homophobia
and plenty of other biases today and in
the past
as we've changed beliefs about same-sex
marriage
more people have been offered equal
freedoms
when we began valuing sustainability
more people began to recycle
so as far as our culture of humiliation
goes
what we need is a cultural revolution
public shaming as a blood sport has to
stop
and it's time for an intervention on the
internet and in our culture
the shift begins with something simple
but it's not easy
we need to return to a long-held value
of compassion compassion and empathy
online we've got a compassion deficit an
empathy crisis
researcher renee brown said and i quote
shame can't survive empathy
shame cannot survive
empathy i've seen some very dark days in
my life
it was the compassion and empathy from
my family
friends professionals
and sometimes even strangers that saved
me
even empathy from one person can make a
difference
the theory of minority influence
proposed by social psychologist serge
moscovici
says that even in small numbers when
there's consistency over time
change can happen in the online world we
can foster minority influence
by becoming upstanders to become an
upstander means instead of bystander
apathy
we can post a positive comment for
someone or report a bullying situation
trust me compassionate comments help
abate the negativity
we can also counteract the culture by
supporting organizations that deal with
these kinds of issues
like the tyler clementi foundation in
the u.s
in the uk there's anti-bullying pro and
in australia there's project rocket
we talk a lot about our right
to freedom of expression but we need to
talk more
about our responsibility to freedom of
expression
we all want to be heard but let's
acknowledge the difference between
speaking up with intention and speaking
up
for attention
the internet is the super highway for
the id
but online showing empathy to others
benefits
us all and helps create a safer and
better world
we need to communicate online with
compassion
consume news with compassion and click
with compassion just imagine walking a
mile
in someone else's headline
i'd like to end on a personal note
in the past nine months the question
i've been asked the most
is why why now why was i sticking my
head above the parapet
you can read between the lines and those
questions and the answer has nothing to
do with politics
the top note answer was and is
because it's time time to stop tiptoeing
around my past
time to stop living a life of a program
and time to take
back my narrative it's also
not just about saving myself
anyone who is suffering from shame and
public humiliation
needs to know one thing you can
survive it i know it's hard
it may not be painless quick or easy
but you can insist on a different ending
to your story
have compassion for yourself
we all deserve compassion
and to live both online and off
in a more compassionate world
thank you for listening
[Music]
you